fue en el vídeo pasado que empezamos a
girar nuestras funciones alrededor de la
siesta
esa vez tomamos la función de igual a x
cuadrada y tomamos el intervalo 0 a 1 y
giramos el área abajo de esta curva
alrededor del eje las 10 con esto yo
obtenía un volumen que era muy parecido
a un tazón era este dibujo que yo tenía
aquí del lado derecho bien en este vídeo
lo que voy a intentar hacer es sacar la
función inversa es decir despejar la x
de mi función y con ello sacar un sólido
de revolución
voy a seguir girando alrededor del eje
de las 10 entonces bien saquemos la
función de inversa pues para esto voy a
pasar el cuadrado del otro lado de la
ecuación es decir voy a obtener una
función de y entonces si yo saco reid de
ambos lados pues raíz cuadrada de x
cuadrada me da xy raíz de yémeda ya
estoy tomando x como función de x es
igual a la raíz de ye y bueno en este
vídeo vamos a seguir girando alrededor
del eje de las 10 en el vídeo pasado
utilizamos el método de los casquillos
sin embargo esta vez dado que tengo una
función de y creo que
sirve utilizar el método de los
casquillos es mucho mejor utilizar el
método que vimos en los primeros vídeos
el método de los discos bien pero viene
la parte difícil la parte que siempre
nos costó trabajo era visualizar el
problema y como decíamos para visualizar
el problema bueno primero voy a colorear
el área que voy a hacer girar bueno voy
a girar esta área y otra área ahora se
va a dar cuenta pero todo va a ser
alrededor del eje de la siesta así que
intentemos hacer de una vez el disco que
nos va a quedar al girar esta función
voy a tomar mis círculos y voy a decir
que está este círculo va a ser mi cara
superior de mi disco y este este disco
pues tiene un cierto grosor ese grosor
ahora lo voy a colorear aquí bien
y aunque esto se parezca mucho al método
de los casquillos no es el método de los
casquillos es el mismo método del
principio del primer vídeo pero al revés
bueno primero que fijaros en el radio de
este disco el radio de este disco pues
es x esta vez pero x es la raíz de ella
entonces voy a poner raíz de jay bien y
además que tiene un cierto grosor este
disco tiene un cierto grosor pero es un
grosor ahora que depende del hierro por
lo tanto mi grosor lo voy a llamar de
james bien ya que tengo ahora mi disco
construido les voy a decir en qué
consiste el problema que me estoy
imaginando yo lo que quiero es tomar un
cilindro con una función de x igual a 1
con él me va a quedar un cilindro
completamente sólido y sin ningún hueco
y después lo que voy a quitarle a ese
cilindro es el área de verde es decir el
área que está bajo de la función de
igual a x cuadrada ese va a ser la idea
de este ejercicio entonces pues hagamos
lo primero voy a dibujar el cilindro de
la función x igual a 1 entonces cómo me
quedaría
gira alrededor del eje leyes voy a
tratar de dibujarlo aquí a un cilindro
que quiere alrededor del eje de la
siesta y que tenga de radio 1 y que sea
completamente sólido entonces esta es mi
cara superior y ahora voy a dibujar mi
cara inferior
y para que no nos perdamos voy a dibujar
el plano cartesiano entonces voy a decir
que este es el eje de las 10 y está aquí
muy bien y este va a ser el eje de las
equis y yo sé que qué distancia hay de
del origen al final de mi cilindro es 1
la distancia no bien pero como voy a
tomar toda la suma de todos mis
cilindros voy a necesitar tarde o
temprano los límites de mi integración y
cuál es el valor más grande que puedo
tomar en 10 es 1 y el valor más pequeño
pues es 0 en este cilindro entonces ya
tengo mis límites de integración y pues
entonces quién va a ser el volumen de
este cilindro de la función x igual a 1
va a ser la integral de pues ya tengo
mis límites son de 0 1 y la integral
recuerden que es la suma de todos todos
los discos pequeños los discos que se
van a atender en finito entonces voy a
dibujar un disco esta va a ser la cara
superior de mi disco y le voy a poner un
grosor el grosor va a ser este de aquí
bien ya tengo la cara superior de mi
disco ya tengo el grosor y lo que voy a
hacer la suma de todos
los sobres el grosor pues vale recuerden
que day es infinitamente delgado
infinitamente pequeño y el radio de mi
disco es ft
ojo aquí es efe de yernos efe de x es
una función que depende de que esta vez
entonces va a ser la integral de efe de
que elevado al cuadrado ésta era mi
fórmula que había un sacado en el primer
vídeo ya esto lo había que multiplicar
por pi recuerden que es el área de un
círculo y después multiplicarlo por el
grosor pero el grosor es de y ya esto
hay que ponerle los límites de
integración quedan de 0 a 1 muy bien
ahora darse cuenta que la idea es
quitarle al volumen de revolución de
radio igual a 1 de la función x igual a
1 el sólido de revolución que nos queda
de la función x igual a raíz de y esa va
a ser la idea ahora quitarle el volumen
del sólido de revolución que nos queda
al girar la función x igual a raíz de y
alrededor del eje leyes por lo tanto a
este primer integrante pueden poner la
integral
afuera efe desde afuera ya esto le voy a
quitar por la integral de 0 a 1 de la
función efe
igual a raíz de g es decir le voy a
poner efe
pero de adentro un sub índice de que
significa adentro esto elevado al
cuadrado x de jeff es decir ya tengo mis
dos integrales que tienen que ver cada
una con mi función una función x igual a
uno y la otra x igual a raíz de jeff lo
que voy a calcular es el volumen que me
queda al restar estas dos al restar
estos dos volúmenes ahora bien ya que
tenemos las dos integrales lo que nos
resta es acordamos quién es cada función
no nos vayamos a confundir entonces la
primera función era la función que
habíamos llamado f
x igual a efe de y recuerden que
habíamos hecho un cambio de variable
igual a 1 era la función igual a 1 bien
entonces me va a quedar pi que
multiplica a la integral de 0 a 1
defendí al cuadrado es decir 1 al
cuadrado de y ya esto hay que quitarle
la integral de 0
a 1 recuerden que 0 a 1 son nuestros
límites de integración de f
elevado al cuadrado pero efe desde
adentro es x igual a la raíz de ella
entonces le voy a poner la raíz del
elevado al cuadrado diferencial de jeff
ok pero el factor común entonces voy a
sacar de factor común la pgje y las
integrales tienen los mismos índices de
0 a 1 entonces una vez vamos a hacernos
pi que multiplica a ver primero tengo la
integral de uno que funciona al derivar
la nos da 1 pues la función que al
derivar la nos da 1 es x están de
acuerdo x la derivada de su no menos
raíz de que elevado al cuadrado pues nos
da
y cuál es la primitiva de pues es
cuadrada entre 2 a esto hay que quitarle
ya se dieron cuenta la nueva que el
error no puede ser x tiene que ser ya
estamos derivando muy bien estamos
integrando con respecto a la integral de
perdón perdón perdón es que esto de
hacer el cambio de variables y todo lo
confundió bueno en fin hay que tener
mucho cuidado con nuestras integrales
y ahora es raíz del elevado al cuadrado
pues se va y solamente tengo jay la
primitiva de pues habíamos quedado que
era cuadradas y lleno si existen que es
cuadrada entre dos bien y todo esto hay
que evaluarlo de los límites de
integración que son de 0 de 1 a 0
bueno pues nada más nos resta evaluar
los límites entonces pues una vez vamos
a hacerlo
esto me queda piqué multiplica uno menos
un medio y ya esto hay que quitarle pues
0 -0 entre 2 o sea 0 0 entre 2 esto no
importa pero el tercero entre 12 0 y 1
menos un medio tampoco importa porque
pues esto es medios no es un medio y que
multiplica pitt son pi medios y si es en
un poco de memoria se van a dar cuenta
que es el mismo resultado que en el
vídeo anterior
de hecho calculamos lo mismo solamente
que esta vez con otro método con un
método de despejar allí es decir tener
todo como función de y es muy importante
de hecho en el otro método tomábamos
discos este verticales y de este método
tomamos discos horizontales
obtuvimos el mismo resultado pero de dos
maneras distintas es una forma de
comprobar que lo que hicimos bien y al
final cada quien puede tomarla la forma
que más le agrade espero no haberlos
confundido mucho y es que hay que tener
mucho cuidado con respecto a quién
estamos integrando mi cerebro se hizo
bolas y al principio vio una integral
con de gea y otra integrado con x hay
que tener mucho cuidado con esto
entonces nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo
que por cierto en el siguiente vídeo voy
a ver un ejemplo mucho más difícil donde
seguramente voy a hacer más errores nos
vemos en el siguiente